hey what is up guys I'm kitty HD here
and this is a nexus 5 running the next
version of Android Android L now this is
nowhere near a complete build in fact
this isn't even daily driver material
it's just a Developer Preview and that's
going to give developers a chance to see
what their apps will look like on the
newest version of Android as they're
making them but that will also give us a
look at what a lot of these new features
in Android L will look like when it's
finally done so without any further ado
let's take a look at the top 5 new
features in Android L so number one is
the new lockscreen and there's actually
a lot of functionality added here so in
android 4.4 kitkat the lockscreen was
really just a place to check the time
and then check to see if you have any
new notifications there's a lot of stuff
added to this lockscreen first of all
you can now swipe up to unlock instead
of pulling out on a ring and you can
swipe left to open the camera which is
the same as before but now you can also
swipe right to get directly into the
phone dialer and of course now you have
your system notifications readable on
your lockscreen without pulling anything
down
iOS style so you can swipe away any of
the notifications to dismiss them or
click on one of them to open it directly
from the lock screen so you no longer
have to swipe down and check to see all
of your notifications there instantly
just be all a tap away as soon as you
wake your phone and then there's the
little things like the updated looks so
the notification bar is now totally
transparent and if you're plugged in you
don't just get a percentage of how much
battery you have but you get the time
remaining until you're done charging at
the current rate I think that is awesome
it's a nice little nifty touch so number
two is the notification panel itself and
this is actually legitimately redesigned
I think it's going to take a little bit
of getting used to and it's definitely
the biggest change to the notifications
we've seen in Android since the
beginning so of course you still swipe
down from the status bar and you get the
new animation to reveal the
notifications here and again you have
the ability to dismiss them by swiping
or tapping one to open it but you can
see here this new look the notifications
are solid but the background is totally
transparent and then you can swipe down
again to get to your quick settings
again redesigned so much flatter with
this great color here no more swiping
down with two fingers or trying to tap
the exact corner quick settings are
super easy to get to now with one
hande and bonus we now have one tap to
cast our screen to a chromecast kind of
like airplay very nifty and an auto
rotate toggle finally we did not have
that before so you can also tap the
notification volume icon to enter a new
do not disturb mode and you have a
volume slider or I should say a pregnant
slider so I like these new quick
settings and the notification panel
definitely looks different and also
there is this new heads-up notification
that Google demoed at i/o so if you get
a call while doing something fullscreen
like reading or gaming it won't totally
take over your screen like it used to
now you can decide to dismiss it and
continue your activity now number three
is material design and Android and this
is one of the biggest talking points at
Google i/o mattias torrid I've spent a
while about it on stage and it's this
new design philosophy about the way
things will behave what I'm getting out
of it is you basically now will be able
to see with animations where everything
came from and where everything goes so
every time a new element appears on your
screen it doesn't just explode on your
screen and appear out of nowhere it
slides in from somewhere or it expands
or grows out of something so it's a new
it's a new look and of course all of the
stock apps in Android L will be
redesigned when it's fully complete but
in this developer preview only a couple
of them are done but we can take a look
at them obviously checking out the
calculator this is one of the most basic
looks at it but again everything slides
in from somewhere and all this movement
and animation gives you confidence about
what you're doing and where things are
going you also see it in the new people
app and the new dialer all these
animations are super smooth and I guess
intuitive even if they're not totally
necessary and Google mentioned its goal
is to have all of these animations
happen at a smooth 60 frames per second
so you'll never noticed any stutter or
lag and I got to say I'm actually pretty
impressed with how consistently smooth
it's been so far on this Nexus 5 so
honestly this is probably the most
important change of this new version of
Android as things move forward I'm
pretty pumped to see more apps moving in
this direction and we'll see what this
ends up looking like when Android L is
done so number four is the new Settings
app in Android L it's actually been
completely redesigned and actually a
little bit reorganized so of course it
starts with the new icon and when you
open it up it is a totally different
look almost looks like someone put a
theme on top of the old Settings app the
scroll effect is different
the animations you get when you get to
the bottom of a list or tap something
that's new and the look of the toggles
and checkboxes have been changed and of
course animated and you have a couple of
other new settings to play with here so
first of all in display settings you
have adaptive brightness now which works
alongside auto brightness and you have
your cast screen option to actually
mirror your display to a TV by a
chromecast
which is pretty cool by itself you also
have a new looking storage settings a
new looking battery history again this
all looks kind of skinned and you also
now have a search box so if you really
can't find what you're looking for in
the settings you can type in the name of
it to get to it quickly and that's a
nice touch obviously we've seen this in
other skins on Android before and that
brings us to number five last but not
least the other stuff there is a lot of
other little stuff that's changed in
Android that you might not notice at
first but they definitely affect the way
it feels
first of all there's a new keyboard and
this is actually available in a
standalone app in the Play Store right
now so I'll link that below the like
button but it's different it's much
flatter much more gray there's there's
also the new do not disturb mode I
mentioned earlier which will get you to
choose how many hours you don't get
notifications there is a new
multitasking which again has that new
look and feel thanks to material design
but of course it stays pretty smooth it
performs well but really that's it I
mean Android L is mostly a visual
overhaul when he compared it to Android
4.4 KitKat besides the fact that it's
switched entirely over to the new art
runtime but it's a new different polish
now you know it's a different type of
feel for stock Android definitely very
different from the typical Android 4.4
KitKat holo look that we're used to it's
basically a departure from holo and it
definitely feels and looks that way it
even kind of reminds me of HTC Sense the
way HTC Sense has been flattening itself
out over the past couple of years we're
starting to see Android in this version
of Android L flattened itself out and
especially that Settings app reminds me
of HTC Sense but there it is guys this
is the new stock Android you'll be
seeing much more of Android L in a
couple of months that follow especially
when they get to the full final release
and we'll see a couple new devices have
it HTC has promised within 90 days of
that release the One m8 will have it I
don't know
anything else other than nexuses will
get android l but fingers crossed that
we see it in a lot more places so the
way that's minute thanks for watching
guys hope you enjoy this video if you're
free to give it a thumbs up if you do
and share it to other people who are
curious about android l thank you for
watching and i'll talk to you guys in
the next one
bass